نقل موقع اكسس الاخباري عن مسؤول الامريكي
تاكيده بان المنسق الامني الامريكي
لاسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه ارسل الى
وزاره الخارجيه تقريرا جديدا حول وفاه
الصحفيه شيرين ابو عقله وبحسب المسؤول
الامريكيه البارز فان التقرير الجديد لم
يتضمن اي معلومات جديده او خلاصات كما كشف
الموقع عن رساله ارسلها السيناتور
الديمقراطي كريس الى وزير الخارجيه دعا
فيها الخارجيه الامريكيه الى اطلاع
المشرعين على نسخه غير منقحه من التقرير
الجديد وقلبان رسالته ان مكتبه ابلغ بان
الاداره تنوي ادخال تعديلات على مضمون
التقرير قبل السماح للمشرعين بمراجعته
واكد السيره الديمقراطي انهم لم تتم
محاسبته اي شخص ولم يتم اكماله اي تحقيق
رسمي مستقل رغم مرور سنه على مقتل شيرين
ابو عقله